last night's State of the Union address
was the epitome of the reality show
State of the Union address and it was
capped by Nancy Pelosi literally ripping
up Trump's speech inches behind Trump's
head as he was mouthing thank you thank
you to people in the audience in
completely cartoonish fashion so we'll
end with Nancy Pelosi ripping up the
speech but that's not where I want to
start so we were live streaming on
YouTube twitch and Facebook during the
State of the Union address and at the
start of the speech I was fact-checking
I was taking notes I was trying to in
real-time correct
the lies and distortions of Donald Trump
and about five minutes in I realized
there's no point in doing this there's
no point in doing this in the
traditional sense the fact-checking here
is pointless number one because it's
just constant lies and distortions and
deception number two because what would
be the point today of going point by
point lie by lie given what the reality
is right now very different than what it
was in times past in the United States
either you are in one of three camps
either you're on the side that knows
Trump is lying and you'd already don't
plan to vote for him you're on the side
that knows Trump is lying or suspects
that he is but you don't care because
you've convinced yourself well all
politicians lie and you're going to vote
for him anyway or you're on the side
that doesn't believe that he is lying
whether or not you're going to vote for
him fact-checking isn't going to
convince you so the point by point fact
check is irrelevant in a sense and I
don't mean it's irrelevant because truth
doesn't matter I mean it's irrelevant
because you either don't need it or it's
not going to affect you just as a couple
of examples there was constant deception
I'll give you one
Trump bragged about how tons of people
got off of food stamps under his
administration take a look under the
last administration more than 10 million
people were added to the Food Stamp
rolls under my administration 7 million
Americans have come off food stamps and
10 million people have been lifted off
of welfare now of course Trump cut food
stamps so it's not really an
accomplishment to say fewer people are
now on food stamps you just cut the
program and kicked people off of food
stamps it's like me saying great news I
was able to get 10 people off of life
support today isn't that great
well did they die when you took them off
of life support
did you cut off life support when they
needed it or are they now breathing on
their own by itself saying there are
fewer people on food stamps is not an
accomplishment one other example Trump
talked about the number of people now
working in the United States is more
than ever before the Republicans love
this and then when it's a Democratic
president they love saying the number of
people not working today is higher than
ever before the population of the United
States continues to grow with a steady
proportion of people working and not
working at almost any point in time you
can say we currently have more people
not working and than ever before and it
would be true and you can also at the
same time say we currently have more
people not working than ever before and
it would also be true it's meaningless
absent any more context so those are
some examples but our time today is not
well spent fact-checking a 78 minutes
minute speech that was riddled with lies
and deception so I want to talk about
the big picture from last night because
that's really what I think matters the
summary the big picture is that this was
a reality show
meant to appeal to the lowest common
denominator using props and pawns and
reality show stunts the guests in the
room who Trump referenced were you know
up in the mezzanine we're for the most
part guests who had nothing to do with
Trump policy at all they were merely
pawns and props and I know every time we
you know every time we make a commentary
like this some people say David you're
insulting those people you're saying
they're stupid and they're being used as
pawns and props it's not that simple if
you're invited to the State of the Union
as the president's guest most people go
and you know to some degree you're upon
or a prop but the do
read to which this was the case
yesterday was sickening example there
was a woman in the mezzanine whose
husband died in combat some time ago
it's horrible it's tragic but it was
wholly irrelevant to any Trump
administration policy any Trump
accomplishment or lack thereof it was
just a woman whose husband tragically
died in combat some time ago there was a
woman in the mezzanine whose daughter
was born very premature and she was
thankfully saved by technology that
Donald Trump had nothing to do with it's
incredibly it's an incredible story
we're so glad that medical technology is
advancing so that more and more babies
born premature are going on to live
healthy lives it's great has nothing to
do with Trump that mom by the way with
the premature daughter also went crazy
cheering when Trump talked about banning
late term abortions which of course are
incredibly rare done in unusual cases
where they truly are necessary and again
that woman was a prop of cheering
against abortion and then the real I
mean just literal reality show stuff a
woman whose husband was deployed to
Afghanistan was there in the chamber
with her kids and in literal reality
show fashion it's sort of but wait
there's more let's see what's behind
door number three sort of moment Trump
says and your husband is not really in
Afghanistan he's here come on down what
a surprise
creating reality television in real time
and then and we're going to talk about
this more yes extremist right-wing radio
host Rush Limbaugh recently diagnosed
with advanced lung cancer as we talked
about on yesterday's bonus show was
there as an invited guest of Donald
Trump's and surprised Rush you have just
won the Presidential Medal of Freedom
and Melania Trump puts the medal on Rush
we're gonna detail that more in a little
bit so then at the end capping the
reality show State of the Union yes
Nancy Pelosi participated in the reality
show she ripped up her copy of Trump's
speech right behind his head check it
out and hilariously you'll hear George
Stephanopoulos here in this clip talking
about Trump's background in reality TV
as Nancy Pelosi rips up
the speech sorter the applause right
there he came out of reality television
and he displayed that talent tonight 78
minute extravaganza touched on emotions
both high and low so there were mixed
reactions to Nancy Pelosi ripping up the
speech some people loved it as a sign of
resistance others said that this is
childish it's really a mix I mean
visually it was very funny and I tweeted
about it and it fits very much with the
whole reality show vibe of what we saw
yesterday
without real action and leadership from
Nancy Pelosi it's merely a funny visual
without any meat or substance behind it
and then the saddest part of course of
all of this is there will be people to
whom this speech really appealed they
saw a soldier's wife and a kid saved by
medical technology that trump had
nothing to do with and they end up
feeling good about Trump because it is
designed to be emotionally manipulative
in exactly the way that it worked on
some people and they'll say I feel
really good about voting for Donald
Trump now in November that is really
hard to fight but we're going to devote
more time to that a little bit later
let's talk now about the rush limbaugh
thing privacy calm is one of our
sponsors and they're giving you $5.00
just for using their free service at
privacy calm slash Pakman privacy's of
service I've been using for a while now
I love it
it saves me a bunch of headaches it's
completely free and it's very quick to
set up and here's how it works when you
pay for something online or over the
phone instead of exposing your real
credit card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers the payments are withdrawn from
your checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant
my real card number I don't have to
companies don't have to know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free they
do have a paid version with different
tiers where you can create more virtual
credit card numbers per month cash back
rewards extra security features but go
ahead and sign up for the free service
it's a no-brainer companies can't charge
you unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy comm slash Pakman